let's make one of my favorite Filipino
desserts Tahoe or sweet silk and tofu
typically I would use this bag of
snuggle pearls but it takes a few hours
so we're gonna go ahead and use this one
instead which only takes three minutes
to cook once the pearls are ready I let
it sit in cold water and while I pop the
Silicon tofu in the steamer for about 10
to 15 minutes I made the Arnie ball
which is a simple syrup made of sugar
water and vanilla extract once the syrup
and tofu is ready it's time for the fun
part assembling it all together scoop up
the tofu and snuggle pearls into a cup
and pour the Arnie ball over it and
repeat until your cup is full enjoy this
delicious and sweet warm dessert